会社での私の主な取引は
、新しいキャラクターが欲しいキャラクターへの攻撃
や
、あなたが自分の武道の経験から引き出した仕事のために戻ってきたキャラクターのようなものをたくさん作ることです。
死んだまたは生きている
プレーヤープレーヤーとしてのあなたの経験から引き出されましたええ、
これはどうですか、これはドゴンです、そして私は私
の友人ケマルと一緒にいます
2本のビデオを長い間待っていました。
私たちは両方とも武道のトリック
をしていました。
その後、大学でAPUで働いていた友人になっ
たり、ジェイソンも学生だったので
、YouTubeのビデオを2本作成しました。
一緒に以下の説明にリンクを入れますが、
ジェイソンは現在
日本のビデオゲーム会社で働いており、日本
のユーチューブとして、日本に
引っ越して仕事をするのが私の夢だというようなことを言う人々からかなりの数の質問を受けます
J  apaneseビデオ
ゲーム会社あなたはこれについて何か情報を持っていますか
、そして明らかに
私は自営業なので私はYouTubeのことをしています
が、ジェイソンはこの分野で多くの経験を持っている
ので、今日は
彼にインタビューするつもりです 約45分で、
彼の現在の仕事からできる限り多くのことを学ぶつもりです。APU
を卒業した後の仕事の経験があると思い
ます。
どのようにしてEPにたどり着いた
かについての1分間のバックアップストーリーは、興味深いことです。ほとんどの
人が日本に来る
と、最初に大学を卒業してから
、私がやったようにジェットプログラムが好きだから
です。  2、3
分ええ、あなたが会社に到着するまで、あなたは
現在クールでクールな仕事をしています。
ジョージア州立
大学で、実はおもしろいです。
実際に日本語の
授業も受けていたのですが、特別な交流があったので、
最初に大阪に行こうとして
いましたが、残念ながら、jlptが必要だったと思います。
あと3回で、タイミングが合わなかったので、次のタイミング
を待っ
て、ランゲージ
センターで友達と話していて
、ランダムに1回だけ話しました。
私が日本に行こうとしているのを耳にした人々の中で
、彼らは実際に交換留学生のため
に実際にまだ開いているこの場所がもう1つ
あるようで、それはちょうどあなたが知っているようなたくさんの電話の直後に
ロイダと呼ばれる場所です ようやく
、なんとかして日本に行っ
て、今年の
um交換留学生プログラムをやることができたので
、その1年の
交換プログラムの約7か月後、私はここで何が好きか知っているようでし
た。 私  滞在するので、
私はこの学校に完全に転校しようとする3分の1のプロセスを進めました。
彼らは、
転校すると
すべての交換クレジットを失うことになるので、大丈夫だと説明してくれました。
とにかく必要な人はみんな行ってもらうだけな
ので交換し
て3年くらいでAPUを卒業して
大丈夫それを
やっているうちに日本にいる間はよく考えていたので就職活動をやって
みよう
シナリオ私はアメリカに帰る仕事を見つけられない
ので、それを通して
私は実際にゲーム会社で今持っている仕事を得ることになりました。私は
あなたにいくつかの質問をするつもりです。
そのプロセスにいくつかのステップがあるかもしれません
そうそうそうそうあなたは州の通常の大学に行きました
そしてあなたは
その大学が後援する交換プログラムに切り替えました
はい部分的にそうそうそしてまたは
それはセットアップされました はいそれg
私は実際には別のスポンサーシップだったので、大学を元に戻し
まし
た。当時はグローバルリンクと呼ばれていました。
彼らはコラボレーションのようなものでした。
そうそう、APUに来たので、アジア太平洋大学で作成されました。
交換留学生として交換留学生として来た大学の名前は、交換の7か月後
に、
APUに転校したいと決めまし
た。そうそう、3年目になり
ました。これは、基本的に2年間のクレジットを取得することができたからです。
ちょうどそのような
パックなので、基本的
に私は自分の専攻に直接向けられたクレジットを取得しました。その
ようなもので101クラスのような多くのフィラーを取得する必要
はありません。apuは5つまたは6つの大学のような数少ないものの1つです
このような日本では
、英語と日本語の両方で授業を受けることができる
ので
、両方の言語で勉強するだけでなく、両方の言語で
大学に入学することができます。
繰り返し
になりますが、以前のビデオで話したことの1つ
は、この時点まで
、人々が日本に住むためにたどる基本的なプロセスパス
は、米国の大学を卒業してから行うということです。
ジェットプログラムのように、または
学位を取得した後に日本で英語を教えて、
それを数年間、おそらく
3〜4年間行い
、その後、翻訳などを行うかもしれませんが、apuは
あなたができる数少ない場所の1つです
高校卒業後
すぐにその会社に会いに行ったのか
、まずは今どの
会社で働いて
いるのかということで、日本のテクモゲームの会社で働いていた
ので もっと具体的に
言うと、アランOHという名前を聞いたことがあるかもしれませんし、聞いていないかもしれません。
忍者と武道に再びジェイソン
と私は
アメリカ
で武道
を騙し
ました アニメ
はまさにチャンネルであり、それは
実際には
後で説明しますが、それが理由の一部であり
、私の頭の中でのようにあなたの思考プロセス全体が私の頭の中で知っているので、私が仕事を
面白くした理由の一部です いろいろなシーンが何度も何度もあり
ますが、
中は大丈夫なので、現在作成中または
開発中
です。あなたが現在開発中かどうかはわかりません
が、
DeadorAliveと アニーああ、あなたは何と
言いましたかええマーベルアルティメットアライアンス3私
がその会社に行ったときの最初のプロジェクトでした
Ompanyや
、APUのしくみのように起こったこと
は、ほとんどの日本の学校が
一般的に働いていることです。学校の最後の1年間に、
実際に就職活動を開始する
ため、少なくともアメリカで
は、あらゆることを行うことが期待されています。
日本では、就職活動の季節のようなものがあります。それは、
一般的に4月の4月の初めに話すよう
に、ある時点であなたを会社に注ぎ込むようなものです。
就職活動だけでいいのですが
、当然、いろいろな
場所を見て、
たくさんのゲーム会社
を探していました。
私のために並んでいましたはい
私が卒業するまでに好きだったようにそれは4月に大丈夫だったようでした
あなたは
今この
仕事に集中する
つもりです どういうわけか興味
があったので、英語をやったと思ったのですが、それは私が
学校で英語を教えていたということでした
。
卒業
時期は2月ですが
、アメリカの通常の
卒業時期は
9月のように監督します
そうそうそうラメール夏正確に
APUは卒業シーズンで
なければなりませんそうそうあなたは卒業した時期に応じて2つの異なる時間にAPUを卒業することができ
ます
高校からえ
えとええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええ 私
は学校のことを心配する必要がなかったので、より多くのクラスを教えまし
た、そしてあなたはあなたがあなたを待っている仕事を持っていました
bハンティングプロセス少しそうそうそうそうそうそうそう
多くの人がそれに
興味を持っていると
思う
どこでも最初の仕事として17年の経験
があり、それは不可能ですが、日本
で
は、学校を卒業したばかりのように、
何も知らないと期待している
ことを理解しています。 私
はマーケティングの学位を持っていても、特定の
場所などに適用されます。なぜなら、彼らは
大丈夫だからです。あなたが
最初に来たとき、彼らは
あなたが知っていることであなたを実際に評価するのではなく、
あなたができる能力であなたを評価しないことを理解しています 新しい
ものを取り入れて、新しいアイデアを取り入れて、学ぶのが好き
だと思います。そうですね、
就職活動を始めました。文字通り季節
なので、アプリケーションが開いたらすぐに行きまし
た。
ウェブサイトのように、hのように言い始めます。
就職活動の
季節などでやってくるので、そういう時は
正確にわかっているので
、英語と日本語のサイトを組み合わせて使って
みました。ただの場所で働きたいだけではないことを知りたいからです。
正直に挑戦したいので、英語が話せるので
、日本語の場所に応募するので、
日本の就職活動
のエチケットのように学ばなければなりませんでした。
ドアを3回ノックして、
X度の角度や広い
都市のように開いてください。私たちのタイプやウォークインのようなものは
、後ろを向い
てドアを閉めないでください。
インタビュー自体は両方の言語でした
ええ、
私がどの会社を探していたかによって、彼ら
が会社で探し
ていたもののよう
に、英語の先生を探していたとしたら
、  n彼らは
私の英語の能力にもっと関心を持って
いました。私が日本に来る外国人のために特別にやっていたポケットWi-Fi会社のようなもののように仕事をしようとしていたことを覚えています。
職場で日本語が話せる
が
、英語での宣伝や会話もできる必要があるので
、特にその会社で
やったように、最初のインタビューは日本語だったと思います
。2回目は2回目のツアー
です。 英語そういうことなので
会社次第だ
な
いろいろ
な設定があります
が、実際に体験したの
は
、会社名は言わないけど、最初のインタビューは演技だったのを覚えています。
あなたがしなければならなかったその種のグループインタビュープロセスは
、基本的にあなたをチームに入れ
、プロジェクトに取り組むようにあなたに言いました、そして彼らは
あなたがどのように働いたか、そして
あなたがどのようなことをしたかを見たいと思っています
そのようなことをし
て、その真っ只中に彼ら
があなたにインタビューしたので、彼らは基本
的にすべての正しいチームABCのようであり、彼らは
あなたがこの種のもののコマーシャルを作るようなプロジェクトをあなたに与えましたが、
あなたは描いた ランダムにたくさんの種類の
帽子か何かが大丈夫のように
私たちは歯磨き粉か何か正しいことについて話している
ので彼らはあなたを入れて
行くと言いますそして彼らはあなたがチームでどのように働いているかを見て
そして
その後 あなたは行って提示する必要がありますそして
それが大丈夫のようにここに
あなたが行動したことを知っている両面コマーシャルがあります
そして1
分か何かのようなものそしてそうですそれは
本当に面白かったですそしてその同じ
会社で次のインタビューの後にええと
だった dそれは
3人のインタビュアーと8
人の応募者のようなものだったと思います。基本的に私たちは皆、
ただ並んでいるか、
この
ランダムな質問をするようなスポット
のようなものです。
2人に同じ質問をしたかもしれませんが
、みんなが
ランダムな質問を
したようなものです。奇妙なことに楽しかったです。何かをしなければならなかったのです
。SPIテストと呼ばれていると思います。
だから私
もSBIテストを受けましたが、基本的には
それが何を意味するのか忘れてしまいますが、基本的に
は能力テストのようなものですが、それは
能力と知識の一種であり、
基本的には日本のIQテストであり
、日本語のIQテストです そうそう
そうそうそうそうそうそうそうそう
そう私がインタビューをしているときに私のSBIテストのように受けたとき
私がどこに応募したの
か私はそれがその応募プロセスの一部であるとは思っていなかったのでそれが何であるかわからなかったことを覚えてい
ます
特に でも仕事なので
、本を開いて
開いて質問に答え始め
て、それを開いたように
、日本語の
三角法のようでした。私の神は、三角法や高度な代数のように勉強していませんでした。
幾何学は
何年も前のように
大丈夫ですこれが10年前のようにこれを行うことができるかもしれませ
んそしてそれは正確には英語ではありません
でした それ
はjlptのような上記の全体のようなものですええ基本的
に日本語のSATのよう
ですそうですそうですそうですあなたが
特定の仕事に応募するときはいつでもミニSATのように取らなければなりませんええええええ
そして私はそうしなかった多くの
人々を想像します
これが今聞いていることだとは思い
ませんが、ブーツが怖いのかもしれませんが
、このビットについてのアドバイスやコメントは、少し余裕があると思います。
外国人にベック なぜなら、私たちが慣れていないという理由だけで
、普通の日本人のように
見ないスコアを取得することは不可能だということを彼らは知っているからです。
彼らは
大丈夫のようです
が、これでも
日本語での説明は
あなたが知っているように、あなた
が日本語を話さないか、そうでないかは気にしないので、それは
あなたの問題です
テストが1つ
あったように、そのセクションで15
分間与えられたセクションの
ようで、最初の3分半のようにスピン
して9つのうち最初の質問を読んで
からそれが得られると約束します。
ですから、これらの漢字の中でのように私に尋ねています。
おそらく
漢字の文字とは8種類違う
ようです。この中で、
この特定の漢字の発音
が他の
漢字とは異なっているようなものです。
シリアルボックスの裏側にある内容の一部
なので、それがどのように言っているのかさえわからないような方法はありません
が、それ自体
は、はい
、[次へ]をクリックするような
ものですが、それが何であるかについては、もう少しです
もう一度そのインタビューに合格することになったので
、彼らはハンディキャップのようなものを与えると思います
ええ
、彼らがその種のアプリケーションを探しているなら、おそらく可能性が
ありますええ、私は
もう1つのコメントを追加します
日本人
学生
は大学時代にそのようなテストを受けるために特別に訓練されました
が、私たちが
正反対のように、それ
はあなたがこの会社にどのような特定のスキルセットをもたらすことができる
かというようなもの
です。 ええ、そうだ
と思います。ええ、彼
が言ったように、私がインタビューを受けているように取ったときは、ええと、そうです、そうです
、そうです、それらのテストのようなもの
がありましたが、私の場合、
それは部分的に運の党派でした
llykill umこれは、
エミネムが彼らに1つのことをしたことについての曲ですが、その
中で起こったことは、
そのすべての中で、um do FS Dolphusと呼ばれるもの
があったので、少し後退する必要が
あります。
生きているフェスティバルのほうが良かったので
、それはまさに
デッドアライブのバレーボールゲームや格闘ゲームのようなものだったと思います。
私は彼女の人生
がすでにそこに行っていたので、
日本に来る前のように私は巨大でした。
死んだライブシーンに競争力をつけようとし
ていて、5時のようにディナー中に
プレイしていましたが、ドリームキャストで2時からプレイして
いました。
もちろんスタッフ
もいたので、トーナメントのように話を
しました
が、同時にコミュニティの一員として積極的に参加して
いました。ただ立っているだけではありませんでした。
周りはこんな感じでした
私がプロデューサーを見たような誰かを見ると、私は
このような絆で
感謝しているようなものでした。あなたは彼に話したいだけで、あなたが知っているように、彼に感謝します。
別の人につながり、
実際には英語のコメンテーターが必要です。
彼らはあなたがコメンタリーをやりたいと思っていた
ので、私と私
はトーナメントの決勝戦で英語のコメンタリーを
やっていたときにチームの他の人と一緒に働いていました。 格闘ゲームの
トーナメントで、アナウンサーのようになります。
ええと、そうですね。
そういうことをした後は、
競合他社や、
英語を話すスタッフのようなスタッフと一緒に食事をし
ました。 プロデューサーディレクターもみんなで
食べに行っ
て、とても
楽しかった
と思いましたが、基本的にはアプリを入れてその場所に応募した時のことでした
。
もちろん、履歴書やエントリーシートが好きではないのですが
、私の写真がすべて
ヒットしたので、お父さん、申し訳ありませんが、はい、そうです。
基本的に
、アプリケーションの履歴書のようなエントリーシートがあります。
アプリケーションとあなたの写真が
そこにあり、どうやら彼らは私の写真を見て、
彼がジェイソンのようなものだったことを
覚えています もちろん、緊張するなら何
でも知っているので、同時に助けになったと思い
ますが、リラックスしたときにいつできるかを知っているので、あの
ように圧倒されることなく、この自信のオーラを
やめることができます 私はすべてを知っている
ので、私はちょっとリラックスしていました私は
はい
のように
大丈夫でした
外国人にとって良い方法おそらく
日本人もそうだねそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそう
あなたが知っていることそれはあなたが知っている人ですええ
ええそしてそれ
は私がインタビューをしている間この1つのポイントが
どのようなものであったか非常に重要
です 私は特にうまくいったと思います。
これは、私がこれが
好きだと言ったときはいつでも、私はこれが好きではあり
ませんが、私が何かが好きではないと言ったとき、私は
ここで
それが好きではない
理由です。 私
はチームに所属していたので、これを変更したいと
思います。
たとえば、私が
話していた具体的な例はありますか
。
スーパームーブのような特別な ゲームのeは
大丈夫なので、私はそれについて話していました、そして
私は彼らの人生が抱えている問題の1つ
はそれがそれほど
派手ではないということです、それであなたがそれを見ているとき何が起こるかは
私が競争力のあるレベルを得たという
ことです
画面にマインドゲームを表示するには
、他のゲームを見ている場合と同じように、
フラッシュが表示されている場合は、
コンボがハードに見えますが、デッド
アライブのようにマインドゲームがたくさんある
ので、私は 私のように、私はあなたが物事を面白くするためにそれ
を整えるためにそれ以外のことをしなければならないようなものでした、
そして私は
あなたが動きを充電するように彼らがあなたのようであるスーパームーブについて話していました
bah bah bahある種のコンボのように、
それらをノックアウトします。私は
、
彼らにキャッチラインのようなものを言ってもらう機会を逃したように感じた
ので
、彼らがやっているのとまったく同じように思ったのです。
それに入ると
プロデューサーのように私が見ると大丈夫のようなものでした
だから私たちがやったのは、
スーパームーブのように、彼らがヒットするの
が好きで、キャッチフレーズのような
ものか、ヒットの右のように終わるようなものだと
言ったので、コンボを入力して所定
の位置にロックする
と、  SBIテストのように、
それはすべての一部であり、
同様に良いことを勉強するの
が好きですが、ええと、私は本当に本当に特定のスキルセットのようなものの大ファンです
何年も何年も何年もの間
、競争力のあるレベルでDead or Aliveをプレイした経験があり
、ゲームについての知識が豊富である
ように、さまざまな話し合いの中で彼らがあなたの情熱を感じることができることを保証できます。
儲かるのかどうかはわかりませ
んが、紙の上のハイスコアなどよりも魅力的だったので、
少し前に戻って
いくつかのことを確認したいと思います。
com トーナメントのようにメンションする
これは日本でしたそう
ですこれはあなたが学生だったときか
、休憩中だったそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそう
日本人のようなものでしたが、日本人のようなものではありませんでした
私は
、日本人の聴衆に向けられた奇妙な種類のようなものは
大丈夫だと言ったので、彼ら
はあなたが たぶん、
最近のように、Twitchで3回ストリーミングし
たり、
ノイズを鈍らせたり、話したりしたり
しましたが、ええと、
特に私がオフィスに行ったときは、私の
ような学生でした。 まるで
彼女の人生が本当に好きだったので
、週末にあなたの息子のようでした。そうそう、私は土曜日のようだった
と思い
ます。
PUでそう私は 文字通り
飛行機のチケットを買ったばかりで東京に飛んで来
て、このイベントで
ゲームへの愛を示すのが好きでした。これ
は私が作ろうとしていたポイントを明確にし
、ポイントは情熱が最も重要であるようです。
学生は
ジェイソンが行っ
たようなことには行かないでしょうし、あなたはそれができないほどのお金を持っていませんが、あなたが行ってあなた
がその情熱を持っているなら、それは私が何かにつながるかもしれません
言いたいのですが
、
今、あなたが話せる
範囲内で、あなたが現在何をしているの
かについて少し話しましょう。
また、
一般的なオフィス環境と同じように
、職場環境と
同じように、勤務時間などについて話すことができるかどうかはわかりませ
んが、
そうですが、基本的には私ができる限りのことです。
会社での私の主な取引は
、attacのようなものをたくさん作ることです キャラクターのks
新しいキャラクターやリピーターが欲しいのですが、
一般的に言って
、社内には10代の人がいるので、
社内のこれらのチーム
はもちろん、プログラマーなどを扱うチームの
ようです。
UIのようなものを扱うチームがあります。
そうですね、私は基本的に
アクションのアクション側にいるので、基本的には
、キャラクターの動きを好きになる方法を見
てみましょう。
多くの場合、新しいキャラクターが出てき
ます。ジェイソン、あなたと
Xさんが一緒になって
、このキャラクターの移動リストを作成する必要があります。
たとえば、新しいキャラクターのようになります。
ニコから出てきたゲームなので
、彼女や
スタイリストのピンクの牛をたくさん作っているとき
は、たくさんの話があったように決められましたが、風の中で決めまし
た 私は大丈夫だと決めました
今はゴーストレディのアートですmm-
hmだからうわーそうです
あなたのようなDVDは、あなたが
知っているようなインターネットの精練を知っています。
私は戦闘スタイルがどのように機能するかが好きです
が、それから地獄にとても興味が
あります。 同時に、私はそれに深く入り込むことはできませんが、
制限もあり
ます。たとえば、これ
は完全に不合理ですが、
私が言ったように、
攻撃したい、または私が大丈夫だと思うことなら何でもいいのです
が、ゲームのシステムを考えなければなりません。ゲームでは
大丈夫です。この種の
攻撃は通常、サイドステップトラッキング
攻撃であり、本当に大丈夫ですか。 私が
3つの高速サイドステップ追跡
攻撃をひもでつなぐために 彼女のようなものは
少し強すぎない
ので、キャラクターを使っ
てやりたいことがたくさんあるようなものがあり
ます。そして、座ってキャラクターの実際の動きについて話すときのように、
私たちはただ
強すぎる、スクラップがない
、逆
に、座って座っていることもある
ので、どのようなシナリオで
この攻撃を実際に使用するのでしょうか。
確かに彼らはすでにこの動きを
持っていますあなたはまったく使用し
ないでしょうあなたは
これを聞いて大丈夫ですかそれを作るためにお金を使うことさえしない
のであなたは
実際の美学について
考える必要があります
プログラムされた格闘エンジンのような正しい用語が何であるかさえわかりませんええええそれは
最終的にゲームバランスのようなものです
ええゲームバランスもそう
ですそしてあなたも私が言おうとしているのは
仕事のためのものです あなたが
あなたはあなた自身の武道の
経験から引き出しました、そしてあなた
は死んだまたは生きている
プレーヤープレーヤーとしてのあなたの経験からも
引き出しまし
た アニメのことを好きで、
あなたが知っているように、私が文字通り
私の部屋に座って、ちょうど私の部屋に座って、
大丈夫のように空想にふける方法を知っているので
、悲しいことにもう私たちと一緒にいないアニメーターがいました
彼は彼がこれらの本当に素晴らしいアニメーションのようなものを作って欲しい
と
思っています私は彼のより有名なものの1つが死んだファンタジーのようなものだと思います
そこに座って、ある種の
空想のようなものを
一度に何時間も、今は何
時間も、長い間好きだった
ので、そのようなもののために、
いくつかのキャラクターを次のように動かすのに役立ちました
明らかに さて、この
キャラクターはこのパンチを持っていますこのパンチはこのパンチを持っている
ので、私の頭の中で私は
コンボが
どのように見えるかを、
美的にそして実用的に好き
なものと同じように遊んでいます
ええ、もちろんそのようなものからも引き出されました
が、
誰もがドラゴンボールを大丈夫のように望んでいます。
それは
私が作っている多くのものに
も入りました実際には1つのもののようにこれ
は一種の人々かもしれませんが気にするかもしれないし気にしないかもしれません
彼女はこのようなヒット曲を
作ったのですが、私は特に
そうだとは思いませんが、彼女はこのようなヒット曲を作ったのですが、私は
そのことを頭に
入れ
ました。 手と私は置きます
彼女の太極拳のバックグラウンド
とそのようなもので
、そういうことを知っているので、それは動きになります。
私もできるときに、ビジネスにクールな小さなヒントを絞る
ようなものです。これについては前に簡単に話しました
インタビューですが、
これはモーションキャプチャや
人形のように行うのですか、それとも主に私が行うのは、
間違ったスティックを紛失してしまうためです。
モーションをどのように進めたいかを説明するためにたくさんの写真を撮ります。または、
もっと簡単な場合
は、モーションを自分でビデオテープに録画して
、仕様書のようなものを作成し、それを
送信して CG
部門はあなたが
面白いと思うので、ジェイソンと私は
あなた
たちがおそらくすぐに見るであろ
うもう1つのビデオを撮影するつもりです。
どのようにあなたは声のようですか
ええ、そうそう、それは面白かった
ので、私はアニメーションをやっています。私は、
攻撃などのようなアニメーションを思いついた
だけでなく、ゲームのシステムボイスで
もあるので、準備の戦いのように聞こえるときはいつでも
、それが私の
夢のキャストをより良い生活でプレイすることは決してあり
ませんでした-高ストレスの場合
、現在の外観でYouTubeで話していると、友達
が声になっ
てしまいます。
7年前でも自分に言い聞かせてくださいねえあなた
はあなたがたくさんプレイしたゲームがあなた
がいつも好きなゲームの1つのようにあなた
が6番目のものを作るつもりでありそして
あなたの声がそれに入るだろうそして
あなたが モーションキャプチャも少し
入っているので、大丈夫だと思います。
前のビデオでもこれについて少し話しました
が、まだ参加していないときは、本当に前向きなメモで終わりたいと思います。 日本、または
日本にいるのに
未来がよく見えないときc 恐らく
、日本でのあなたの将来について一種の
悲観的な見方をするのは簡単かもしれませ
ん。 スティーブ・ジョブズを引用するの
はこの時点では非常に決まり文句だと言って
いましたが、
スタンフォード大学の卒業式のスピーチ
で、彼が言ったことの1つは
、あなたが人生を歩み、すべてに到達する過程にあるということです。
繋がっていないように見える
さまざまなポイントの
ようにこれらは異なります 日本語では
気になりませんが、私は3、4年間、
自分の能力を最大限に発揮して
お金を稼ぎませんでした。それから
、友達のようにああと思っていたところまで来まし
た。 家は彼らがいるようなものです
彼らがどんどんお金を稼いでいる企業のはしごを上っていく
と、ここでは
お金
がないようですこれがうまくいくかどうかはわかりませんが
、YouTubeのような
ものです
その時点までに行ってきたすべてのハードワークを活用し
て、それを収益化すること
ができました。あなたが同じ
ような状況にあるように思えます。
本当に本当に何時間も何時間も武道に費やしていることを知っています
-死んでいるか生きているか-日本に来る-
一般的に崩壊しますええそれは
一般的にゲームですそして再び
私が作ることができるように作るつもりのように視覚化するのは難しいです
いつの日かこのようなキャリアを築きました
が、以前のビデオの1つで最後に指摘し
たのは
、既存のポジションに自分を合わせるのは難しいという
ことですが、独自の
スキルセットを持っている場合は あなたの強い
強いスキルに満ちています ポジションをクリエイティブにすることができ
ますはい
あなたが今やっているようなことをしている人は誰も知りません
似たようなことをした日本人がいることは知っていますが、あなたのユニークな
スキルセットと経験により、あなた
は強力な敵マイケルを
やって
いる外国人になりました。
あなたが
私に質問をしたとき、私はこれに触れるのを忘れたことに気づきましたが、ええ、私は
私のチームで唯一
のようです 侵略者の場合、
日本人以外の名前を探す必要はありません。ええ
、
日本に来たいと思っている人への私の一番のアドバイス
は、伝統的に評価されていなかったとしても、彼はそのスキルセットを見たのです。
テクノロジーがTwitchの
ようなYouTubeのようなもので進化している方法
で、そして将来的に来るもののように、この特定の瞬間に収益化
することができないスキルを収益化できるかもしれない
ので、貴重なまたは儲かるスキルセットとして使用されます。 それは私が終わらせることだと思い
ますあなたが言いたいこと
やあなたがしていることのようなものをプラグイン
することは
あなたが知っているようにあなたが得たもののように最高になるように努めてくださいそして
もちろん人々は考えるでしょう ああ、私
はこれが得意でなければなら
ず、CSのように
、この1つ、もう1つが得意な
場合もあり
ますが、情熱を持っているだけで、実際に大丈夫なものがある場合は、
一歩下がっ
て、あなたが情熱を持っていることを言ってください。
私
はたくさんの人に会い、彼らは特に情熱を持っていないので、本当に重要です。
しかし、
あなたが何かに情熱を注いでいるとき、それが示すものに情熱を注ぐことが
できれば、それ
だけでなく
、どんな仕事でも、どんなことでも、それに伴う困難な時期を
乗り切ること
ができると思います。
あなたの情熱があなたをそれを通して引き抜くので、あなたはそれ
を
もっとうまく取ることができ
ます
怠惰な開発者や何か正しいものの
ように、または彼らが
これについてどのようにそしてそれについてコメントを持っ
ているかもしれないかのよう
に
私はゲーム全般に情熱を注いでいるので、ビデオゲームの制作
を止めさせないようにしてい
ます。だから、あなたが情熱を注いでいるものを見つけて、
それを回避できるかどうかを確認してください。
同様に、ええと、ええ、それのために行き、
そしてまた 恥知らずなプラグとして、
私は私のツイッチチャンネルでこの
ようなことについて少し話しました。 そしてチャットは私に
質問をします私はそれがノーゴーなら
私の能力の
限りでは彼らに答えません私は申し訳ありませんが私
はそれに答えることができないようになります
作り始めた動画
、最初に作った動画、
4年前
のこの時点で30秒くらい
をここに入れ
て、ジェイソンが作りたいと思っているのは楽しいです。
私は一緒にこのビデオを作りまし
た。彼はまだAPUの学生
でした。これは、私がYouTubeに公開した2番目のビデオでした。
彼がお気に入りのビデオゲーム会社で働いている今、将来はどうなるかわかりませ
んでした。
あなたの好きなビデオに合わない場合は、誰かの中で
確かに彼らの間で簡単に死ぬ
そうですそして今私はフルタイムでYouTubeをやっている
ので情熱を持ってあなたの
夢の子供たちに従ってください私はあなたがベンアフレックについて話していることを意味し
ます 超音速として知られています